your best hour today what you do in that
hour is going to be worth more than the
rest of the day combined that long to do
list you have that 10 things that you
say you're going to do today one of the
things on your list if you did that will
be worth more than doing everything else
on the list combined
kristoff welcome to the show
honored to be here chris good to see you
good to see you too man so the last time
that we spoke was in the car park of
cosmic coffee
across the street from where i was
staying in austin and you were gearing
up for a very big
poker tournament
that was happening quite soon tell me
tell everybody what that was and let me
know how you got on
sure so i went on a bit of a poker
sabbatical uh in june of last year i
wanted to take some time
to travel and focus them on some other
things maybe have a normal schedule for
a while
and i got alerted to
a private tournament that was happening
and the tournament was denominated in
bitcoin so it was attracting a lot of
people who were let's say whales in the
uh the crypto ecosystem necessarily
poker whales but people who like
generally good to play with and i was
obviously intrigued
i don't consider myself
a tournament player but this was the
possibility of playing in a very large
buy-in tournament with people who i
think i would have a pretty big
advantage on so i took myself out of
semi-retirement for
you know the fifth or sixth time and uh
went on to a
training program both in tournaments but
also you know physically mentally to
develop the
discipline the stamina the presence that
i thought would allow me to maximize
this opportunity
and you got out there and talked me
through that
oh i'm gonna get in trouble i wish i
wish i knew this was coming uh i think i
played very well uh as in many things in
life uh the cards fall where they may uh
there's many times in poker
really success in poker is you have lots
of these 55 45 spots where you're 55 to
win and you just get enough of these and
eventually you're stacking all the money
in the world right it's like when i play
cash games i get enough hands that all
these small edges compound and multiply
and the best possible situation that you
can get into in texas hold'em is that
you're an 80 20 favorite meaning that
you're going to win 80 of the time
and in this case i got all in pre-flop
with pocket kings against pocket tens it
was a scenario that i had been setting
up all day and it went exactly how i'd
written it up and if i win this hand
which i'm going to win 80 of the time
i'm the chip leader in the tournament
and based on who was left and the
situation so this was approaching the
money bubble
uh those of you guys who don't play
tournaments the bubble is right before
the payouts begin
so usually people really tighten up they
start being a lot more risk-averse
playing less hands because no one wants
to walk away empty-handed so if you are
in no danger
of losing as i would have been having
the most of the chips you can really
ramp up the aggression and put a lot of
pressure on players and chip up very
quickly so i i believe that i had i won
this hand there were five players
remaining at the time uh i was i was a
heavy favorite to win the tournament
alas a 10 comes on the river uh and i am
out of the tournament
and it's always important especially
when you are playing a single hand for
uh well over six figures in expectation
and you're mentally counting the chips
and all of a sudden you are standing up
but everyone's kind of
feeling a little bit bad for you but
also internally very grateful that the
best player left is no longer in the
tournament
you just kind of have to tell yourself
is uh this is what 20 feels like
20 of the time i'm going to lose and
this is one of those times
and i did everything that was in my
control so
[Laughter]
i mean i i really try not to tell
you know bad beat stories as no one
likes to to hear them but it's
it's you know the life can be
mentally grueling sometimes things
aren't always going to work out the way
that you planned it and all i could do
walking away from this is i did
everything that was in my power to set
myself for victory for weeks ahead of
time you know i really ramped up my
physical training i was working with a
coach to teach me like the the
detailed
mathematics of of tournament poker like
tournament poker is all just
memorizing a 10 000 page book by reading
it over and over again he was fast
tracking me and all the math and
i took a course on tells so i could read
people's body language
i stayed at the ritz carlton
for multi thousand dollars a night the
the times before and spent a lot of time
at the spa to just walk in there feeling
like i've already won where i'm playing
with literal crypto billionaires and
feel wanting to feel like a billionaire
myself i put a lot of effort into
preparing for this one day and in one
moment it was all over and all i could
say is well i regret nothing i did what
i could dude that's one of the things
that really impresses me about you the
you have this systems focus but there's
another side to you and it really came
out when we got to have a late night uh
alcohol free beer at cosmic coffee and
um
you have like a you have a spiritual
side to a lot of the things that you do
uh this sort of equanimity that i think
you're able to to find which kind of
helps to counter the ruthless side of
productivity so you know systems focused
really bothered about optimizing and so
on and so forth but then there's this
other element to it maybe like the yin
to the yang or whatever um
that is a really nice counterweight and
you're able to find this equanimity in
peace with you know what is just
i mean there was what it was it would
have been millions i'm gonna guess on
the line had you have ended up carrying
through to the end and instead you're
sort of dusting your hands off and
saying good luck with the rest of the
game boys
yeah i think as i have grown older and
hopefully matured i've become
more philosophical
and much more interested in
my subjective experience of reality i
think in my younger years i was very
hard driving
and i think a lot of that was fueled by
scarcity
feeling like i wasn't enough that i
needed to
accomplish certain things or else i
would be a failure or i would be
insignificant or that
all of my perceived you know gifts
talents potential would have been wasted
and why am i here
and i think that
while i don't regret that i think you
know it's like the what it's what got me
here
essentially it's what allowed me to have
lots of really
powerful experiences and lessons and try
many things that although they terrified
me i thought were necessary in order to
be this kind of pedestal version of a
success
i i don't think that that is
sustainable
and i realize only in hindsight that it
caused me a lot of stress anxiety and
unhappiness and as i've zoomed out on my
life realizing that
accomplishments in themselves don't
really matter i'm much more interested
in feeling fulfilled and feeling happy
and being you know positive influence on
the people who i'm fortunate enough to
intersect with
and a lot of that that scarcity can come
at the expense of that so
you're thinking about the flip side of
it i try to embody again this is an
intention this is a practice that i come
back to i can't say that i'm here every
day but just this perspective of i've
already won
i don't need to do anything else i don't
need to learn anything else i have
nothing else to prove like i'm already
here i've already won and operating from
this position of i don't need to do
anything i can just enjoy have fun trust
that the universe is going to present me
opportunities that i can choose to
accept or not uh it feels a lot more
gentle it feels like this this weight
has been lifted
and especially when you operate in
fields like poker
or i've gotten much more into investing
in the last couple years and consider
myself a at least a part-time
investor
you need to have that separation between
the results on your bottom line and who
you identify with um because if if you
are too susceptible
to these short-term fluctuations of
chance
uh you'll be wrecked you'll just be
completely r-e-k-t
wrecked because you're gonna be punched
in the face
how do you i'm fascinated by this and
it's something that i think i'm uh
calling on your coattails about as well
how do you walk yourself
from being the sort of person who is
hard charging takes pride in their
outcomes in life takes pride in doing
things properly and optimally and
being as efficient as possible
how do you blend that desire to do well
to get the right outcomes
with uh an acceptance of
perhaps not always getting the outcomes
that you want of doing everything that
you could have done and yet still
not getting the outcome that you wanted
how do you marry those two things
together
sure
as we've talked about before it's a core
belief of mine that there's no growth
without goals
that
this whole okay i'm just going to keep
improving on all these dimensions but
not having clarity on
why i'm doing things or
if i'm making progress it's just a
recipe for spinning wheels to just keep
running on this treadmill and sweating
but not really getting anywhere so i do
think that it is very important to have
a goal in mind something that you are
heading towards that you are training
for that you can even if it's not
quantitative that you can track progress
is what i'm doing on a day-to-day basis
leading me to where i want to be this
vision of who i want to be in the future
or where i want to be in the future this
internal coherence is the psychological
principle i think that is critical and
it applies to everything even though
let's say you're you're in the gym for
example it doesn't matter how much you
can deadlift it really doesn't matter
that that number doesn't matter but if
you aren't tracking it it's hard to know
if you're making progress if those
efforts are paying off so i think it's
really important for everything that you
do having some form of tracking even if
it's just in a journal you're regularly
saying how do you feel like how was
today did it make you happy was there
things that were cool that you're
grateful for you're celebrating having
this place to capture
is what i'm doing leading me to where i
want to be i just want to jump in there
chris because this is
a really important point that i never
thought of before reading your article
and anyone can google there is no growth
without goals chris sparks and it will
come up on your forcing function website
because of how popular atomic habits
became and because you do not rise to
the level of your goals you fall to the
level of your systems became like a
[ __ ] epitaph right that people would
just it's going to my gravestone i'm
just focused on the systems and the
processes bro the results will take care
of themselves but there's a tension here
between these two right that we need to
we know that enjoying the journey is
what we should be aiming on that
presence is something that we should be
fundamentally focused on we also know
that getting the process right is the
only way to get the results that we want
but i i genuinely believe that in that
sentence which is great from james but i
do believe that there is something
that is missing from that and if you
read earlier in the paragraph what he
says is that goals are great for giving
us direction
however they're not sufficient on their
own
and i think that that myopic focus that
people have had and i've had this myself
as well you know to just forget the
goals right i'm totally not goal driven
at all you do realize that you end up
putting a lot of time in working
incredibly hard to try and do a thing
and you're like well okay what's this in
service of like what what is this hard
work actually getting me to what is it
getting me toward anything how do i know
that the thing that i'm focusing on the
process of is moving me in a direction
that i want to it could be taking me in
the wrong the complete wrong way
i think that's right on the money and
it's as you said it's very nuanced and
it's very tempting when you're looking
at something like goals or systems to
take a dichotomous approach and goals or
everything or systems are everything i i
do believe this sort of score takes care
of itself is true that if you are able
to stay consistent with something the
the phrase that i like to say is
ensuring continuous improvement if you
have systems that allow you to keep
improving on things
at forcing function we have something
that we call the improvement loop we
talked about this a little bit last time
when we were going over the annual
review that i think at any given time
we're doing one of three things we're
planning
we're executing we're reflecting so
planning let's think about this as the
goals phrase like where do we want to be
let's create a road map of how to get
there
the execution i think it's like it's
like experimenting we're trying things
we're tracking this is like the um
we're see we're just doing things we're
observing the feedback that we get from
our environment from the from the
universe and just kind of like you know
bumping up against reality and then this
reflection i think about this as the the
systems aspect we're fine-tuning what
we're doing we're seeing what's working
doubling down on that if we try
something it's not having the it's not
leading having the progress towards the
goals that we would like we course
correct and that feeds back into the
plan so i don't see these as
independent
i think they are both part of this
continuous loop that we are iterating
through
the second part of your your question
and i think this is again this is where
i get a little bit more philosophical
but this
mindset i think is really necessary for
the sustainability of staying in the
game for a long time and not burning out
is that you can have this direction you
can have these very specific goals but
not be attached to them when i say being
attached to them like identifying
with their success that you succeeding
in this goal means that you have
succeeded and thus you are a success and
the inversion of that is if you fail to
achieve this goal you have failed and
you are a failure so that's always the
balance that i am trying to strive for
and to try to instill in others is that
you can be trying really hard and going
after really ambitious things but not
being attached to needing to achieve
them it's more the pursuit that is
important
a question that might have popped up in
some people's minds is
if my successes don't make me a success
then what does make me a success
i'm not sure that i'm qualified to
answer i'm not sure because
i i do think it really comes down to
identity
and
all i can think is to speak from from
personal experience
um i try to operate from that
perspective i shared earlier of i've
already won and this frame is i've alrea
i'm already a success not because of
anything that i've done but because i'm
here i'm in the arena i'm working on
things i'm improving i'm not attached to
any results that come from that
and i think that really
empowers me to be
curious and to have fun with it because
no matter what happens i'm already one
i'm already a success uh i i feel like
just approaching things with this this
gentleness this lightness um
really really empowers us well dude if
you're able to do that if you're able to
attach a light touch to a 100 000
bet on a couple of million dollar
tournament i think that you know pretty
much everybody else can but this this
entire sort of area of
in the modern world if we are what we do
then our successes define who
are worth
to the world
um i think that this entire area really
fascinates me and i think that
when you don't have typical roles
especially if you're young and you don't
have a family yet and maybe you haven't
contributed to your local community
maybe you haven't had the sort of impact
that you've wanted to on other people
just yet
you think well okay so what am i like
what what is a firm place for me to
stand
that gives me something that makes me
feel enough aside from the
ephemeral
daily
successes or losses victories and
failures that i go through you know and
this is what you were saying earlier on
that
if your sense of self-worth is
predicated on such a fine margin that
the last thing you did being good or bad
determines your self-worth up until you
get the opportunity to like shake the
echo sketch eraser and then draw
something new that's far too turbulent
of a situation to be in like you need to
be able to find firmer ground to stand
on there's a quote i put in my
newsletter the other week that was from
nathan jones and he says there is no
scarcity only opportunities all around
us that we cannot yet perceive
scarcity is a spiritual condition it is
projected from out of us into our world
and that's so true
there is no scarcity there is only
opportunity out there there is an
infinite number of things that you could
do an infinite number of ways that you
could find joy and presence and
happiness in the in the current moment
and yet
because of the way that we choose to
frame the situation that we're in we see
it as scarcity
yeah i think we operate in a culture
that really rewards delayed
gratification
that
pushes satisfaction and happiness out
into the ever receding future
uh
and if we're operating out of this place
of lack
i have a spoiler for you like there's
always going to be lack like if you okay
when i hit this number in my bank
account or when i my audience hits this
size
or when i get this strong or i have this
type of network whatever it is that
that goal post is always going to keep
moving if you're operating from the like
when i have then i will be or like you
know when i when i've accomplished this
then i can take a vacation then i can
take a step back then i can feel good
about myself and i've been there before
for most of my life and on some days
unfortunately i've i lapse back into
that and operating from this place of
lack
in buddhism they call it
samskara it's a it's a hungry ghost that
you could never feed enough that if you
if you have lack no amount of
satisfaction will ever satisfy you
dude it's like running toward the
horizon that was what ben hardy said you
know if every time that you take a step
toward your goals you decide to move
them further away or morgan housel in
the psychology of money says the number
one way to become financially free in
the game of finances is to stop moving
the [ __ ] goal posts like keep the
goal post still and you might be able to
score but if every time that you take
you kick the ball toward them you decide
to move it further away you're never
ever going to reach it and um again
i think that it's such a rare thing to
hear
enoughness used as a term because what
everybody celebrates at the moment is
you know
unless you're part of the uh whatever it
is fire movement that retire early
financial independence retire early
movement
everybody is saying well yeah you've
made a mill so now it's time to leverage
that and make ten and now that you've
made turn it's time to leverage that and
make 100. you go well
why
genuinely why what what is it that you
can get with a hundred million that you
can't get with ten
what do you want dynasty wealth are you
trying to sort the next 20 generations
of your children out like what is it
that you're trying to do with this or is
it just that you have become caught
you've become captured by this game of
feeling like the solution to your
feeling of insufficiency is going to be
sorted on the other side of the next
zero that gets added to the bank account
it's hard for me to emphasize enough
that i've realized that acceleration
comes from slowing down
that what's something the more
the more that we can sit and be quiet
and think and listen especially to what
do we really
want rather than listening to
this mimetic what everyone else thinks
that we should want or tells us that we
should want the more that we will be
able to take the most direct path
towards what we really want
and
i think it's really
dangerous
and pernicious even
to
look at what everyone else is doing as
the example of what we should strive for
and yet that's how we all live our lives
so it comes back to this old annoying
but very true idea of the inner
scorecard of actually thinking about why
are we here and what that would look
like and trying to put the blinders on
what everyone else is doing that hey
these these are all opportunities as you
said but
they're not the opportunities for me i
don't need to succeed in the way that
everyone else thinks that i should
digging into the concept of what do you
want to want is a pet obsession of mine
and yours as well i think
as a
talented person that might be listening
to this or as yourself you know you
could have done the poker route the
investing route the coaching people
route and then probably a million other
things that you didn't even decide to
start
how have you decided to focus on the
things that you do in life without being
tempted by the other things that you
could be doing
it seems to me that there's almost a
little bit of a curse of talent that if
you have um abilities that you could
deploy in different directions that the
paradox of choice comes up and a lot of
the time that means that people get a
little bit done everywhere and don't
actually make any meaningful progress
anywhere
there's two approaches that i come to
with this the first is knowing what
value that i'm optimizing for there's a
really powerful exercise that we've
adopted from a book called the fifth
discipline field guide that's called the
top values exercise
we can we can drop it in the show notes
um we have we have it in a notion doc
that anyone can use
essentially it starts with what are all
the things that you value take this long
list of 100 things and maybe you're like
hey 40 or 50 these things yeah i value
that that sounds like a good thing well
then you have to start limiting down the
list so what are your top 10 values what
are your top five values this is where
people start to get really really
uncomfortable what are your top three
what are your top two what is your top
value
and
this is where like when you have to
start to make these trade-offs is like
okay is family most important to me is
financial freedom most important to me
is my personal development most
important to me is is my health most
important to me
it doesn't matter what the answer is
because there is no right answer except
what you think the right answer could be
but once you decide that hey
x is most important to me
x comes first you decide that health
comes first and you're only sleeping
five hours a night because you're hard
driving on your startup well that should
cause a little bit of dissonance and you
said health is most important to you but
clearly you're acting as if it's not
most important too i work with clients
who say that family is their top value
but don't get to see their kids as much
as they would like well that should
cause a little bit of dissonance you
said family is your most important but
the actions that you're taking aren't
alignment with that right it's a kind of
a
a cognitive canary if you will right the
idea you have canaries in the coal mine
if the canary dies there's something
wrong in egypt it's like hey
i say this is most important to me but
you look in my calendar you look at what
i'm doing
uh there's a disconnect here either i
believe this i want to believe this is
most important to me and it really isn't
and that often is true right like your
actions are your best indication what
you're doing or
i need to change the way
that i'm investing my time my energy my
attention into the things that are
actually most important so this is a
really good call out exercise that i
recommend
the second is a little bit more
intuitively driven and this is coming
back to the the slowing down
is just to listen to what resonates um
what gives you energy what makes you
feel most alive the days that you're
most excited to get out of bed in the
morning like what else is is going on
and really tapping into that for for me
if i if something is feeling draining or
i'm procrastinating on it or it feels
like an obligation
that's a signal from my subconscious
that something is going wrong that i'm
not acting in alignment and maybe i need
to change well what would you say what
would you say to someone that was like
well chris not everything that i do is
going to be [ __ ] sunshine and
rainbows it's great for you as the poker
pro that owns his own business but some
of us need to grind our work out i can't
just decide to put tools down at graft
because i don't like this job anymore
there are certain necessities that i
need to do as well
absolutely um i'm thinking about moments
and i'm thinking about trajectory
i don't think this is a
need to
you know need to quit your job today and
like go to the ashram and meditate or
like all right well yeah
it doesn't matter that you you know you
don't have as much money in the bank as
you need to support yourself like burn
the boats and like go go create the
chris williamson coin and just like yolo
there's there's clearly uh
like constraints that need to
be met
um you know we always come back to those
those pillars like are you doing we need
to be healthy are you
giving time to your important
relationships your family your
significant other your closest friends
are you putting yourself in a position
in terms of your career that you are
building skills that you are building
network social capital
uh that you are setting yourself for a
positive trajectory like
all that foundation needs to be there
and to build with and i'm i would never
tell someone to just like drop
everything because you don't like what
you do or you know the city that you're
in but it's important to have this north
star and i think in terms of setting
direction this is a very
cool place to start from is what are
those moments that make you feel most
alive and perhaps you can find ways to
make those happen more often even if
it's just internal even if it doesn't
mean making any large scale changes in
your life but to find more of those
moments and to amplify them there's a
story that i heard about both elon musk
and about jeff bezos that they had
single
uh objectives like a unifying goal that
both of their companies were working
toward elon's words does this get us
closer to mars
and bezos is was does this improve the
customer experience
and one of the things for the first time
ever at the start of last year i did a
proper formatted annual review which is
your process and in that because you
have a single north star for each of
your four areas for health
uh careers relationships and like a
personal development thing
inherent in one north star
is
not the yes that you say yes to it's the
no that everything else has the no said
to and
that that really really did make such a
profound difference last year because
i knew
all of the things that kept on coming up
to tempt me
is it in service of that thing the one
thing this is what you said it was going
to be and it's only a year and this is
the other thing you know a lot of people
might feel a bit of existential crisis
around
like sparks poker guys said that i've
got to choose the thing that my life is
about it's like yeah the thing that your
life is about
for now
not the thing that your life is about
for the rest of time this isn't you
setting yourself on the next 60 years
it's you
for how long for three months for six
months for 12 months or something
it's so powerful i i i just so many
things i want to expand on there so
first yeah you're not choosing what you
want to do with your life you know this
is not talking to your high school
guidance counselor like what a scary
question and like how boring would that
be if you knew exactly how what you're
going to be doing for the rest of your
life all you are doing is picking a
direction to head
and this is why i always come back to
this experimental framework is you pick
a direction and constantly
the world the universe your friends your
followers the environment are giving you
feedback on whether you are on the right
track or not so commit to a time period
i say a month is a great default uh
maybe if it's something that requires a
little bit more commitment like starting
a business moving to a new city maybe
you want to make it around three months
but commit to that
and the power is for that time period
you are giving it all that you have you
were giving the experiment full to room
to run and you're not worrying every day
like did i make the right choice maybe i
should have done this other thing
instead because at the end of that
period you have the full opportunity to
double down or stop do i want to take
the next step with this or do i want to
try option number two and i think that's
a really key
lesson with this choosing one north star
this is so hard for people and it's so
hard for myself i do this exercise
myself and it's painful because i sit
there i've created the damn thing and
i'm like i want to write down five goals
because i can't choose just one and i
have to like literally cross them out
like killing your children
it's like yes it's
everyone
everyone when they hear the word
distractions is like oh i'm sitting on
youtube or me i'm playing settlers of
katan or
netflix or twitter scrolling no the most
dangerous distractions are the ones that
feel productive to you because it's you
working on that number three number four
number five goal to procrastinate
on moving forward your number one goal
that our speed is fastest right when we
slow down we understand what is most
important to us and we put the blinders
on everything else and that that's why
that pain of making that first decision
allows you to move quickly and with full
conviction on that number one north star
and that's why i'm such a big believer
in it so it's not
necessarily like
waiting until you are sure this is the
right thing
don't wait just take your best guess
just pick a thing pick something yes
pick a thing it does not matter but you
have something to shoot for that you are
you're focused on and as you move
towards it you will learn so much more
than on the sidelines trying to plan the
maddest thing is how liberating that
feels
it's so liberating to know that there is
one thing that you're moving toward and
you don't realize until you've done this
you don't realize how much of your day
is spent
measuring the relative benefit and cost
of a bunch of different decisions that
you could make okay so i didn't really
sleep very well last night and i've got
this thing to do at work tomorrow but
i'm supposed to go to the gym tonight if
i go to the gym tonight i'm going to be
tired for work tomorrow if health was
your number one priority you wouldn't
care about how you're going to perform
at work tomorrow and if work was your
number one priority then you wouldn't
care about the fact that you're leaving
the gym i know that's a really obvious
like simple example but then imagine
that across every decision that you need
to make and it's just this snow plow
like that snow pl piercer train just
plowing the [ __ ] out of everything and
it's just on a set of tracks and it's
going in the direction and a decision an
opportunity pops up and you just forget
about it because it doesn't contribute
the decision pops up and you forget
about it he said
about how
the most dangerous procrastination tools
aren't the things are obvious
procrastination they're like the shadow
projects that we do which are mere
reflections of the main project we're
supposed to do and in the war of art by
stephen pressfield he talks a lot about
shadow careers so he spent a lot of time
in la and hollywood around
actors and film business and he said
that he found a lot of lawyers and
agents for actors were failed actors so
what they'd done is they'd wanted to go
and pursue this career but they hadn't
quite decided to commit fully because it
was so risky so they'd gone into this
sort of proximal analogy career this
thing that was close enough to it this
ancillary part
it's a bit of it but it's not really it
but it satisfies the part of us and
that's the worst thing like you could
have just if you're going to be a
[ __ ] agent for an actor with the
dreams of being an actor you might as
well just go and be an actor like you're
already doing 50 of the stuff like just
go and commit the full the full hog
alternatively go and do something else
so yeah i think
what are the ways in which you convince
yourself that you're doing the work but
it isn't the actual work you're supposed
to be doing those are the dangers and
i've seen that so many times oh i've got
this website copy to finish for like to
finish the main thing that is important
but oh i could write a new script for a
youtube video oh i could do some guest
research or do whatever it's like no
what's the main thing you're supposed to
do focus on that
in in venture capital they have this
model of
power law right i think in the pandemic
we learn a lot about exponential returns
and in venture capital you raise a fund
you go out you invest in like 30
startups and
one of those startups is going to have a
better return on investment than the
other 29 combined that's what the power
law means is that
one of these things is going to be worth
more than everything else combined and i
think this applies to the way that we
spend our time
that your best hour today what you do in
that hour is going to be worth more than
the rest of the day combined that
long to do list you have that 10 things
that you say you're going to do today
one of those things which by the way is
probably not on that list because no
one's asking you for it one of the
things on your list if you did that will
be worth more than doing everything else
on the list combined but the danger is
that we we measure our productivity and
the number of boxes that we check the
number of things that we get done rather
than the progress that we make towards
our goal and right coming back to the
importance of really slowing down to
decide what's most important because
progress towards that
is better than progress on everything
else combined so it's this one decision
that's hard but makes all of the other
decisions super easy like you said
you're a freight train just plowing
through
so that that's why i always come back to
like what is most important how can i
prioritize that how can i make sure that
it comes first at the expense of all of
these other things that i can just
justify later so if you're thinking
about this this could be whether you're
a manager or whether you're just trying
to manage yourself right you're thinking
about oh did i have a good week this
week well it'd be very easy to say oh
like i did this thing i did this thing
that you list out all the things that
you did well let's imagine that you had
just one goal for the week and you were
like well is this a good week well i did
all these other things well that doesn't
matter did you make anything
towards the goal yes
i see this all the time when i work with
my performance coaching clients we have
a session and for me the whole goal of
the session is to give them three things
at the end these are the three things
that i recommend that you do for next
time i don't come up with them they come
up with them they say hey i should be
really doing this it's like hey that
sounds like a really good idea maybe you
should be doing that let's define it
let's be very clear on what you're going
to do what are those steps what does it
look like if you're going to be done
where you're going to accomplish it why
it's important to you and i'm like hey
are you committed to that like yeah i'm
going to do that it's like cool i'm
running down you're going to be doing
this great write down these three things
i send them in an email afterwards do
one do two do three and then the next
time that i see them i'm like hey how
are things going and they tell me about
things four through thirty that they've
like no no i don't care about any of
those those three things that we decided
last time are by far the most important
things for you be doing how are those
going it's so funny how we want to pat
ourselves on the back for doing all
these other things that are just a
mechanism for avoiding what's most
important
one of the things that i've heard you
talk about to do with your poke game is
uh confidence from evidence that you
know what you're doing right the fact
that if you've done something repeatedly
over and over but there is an element in
here of uh intuition versus cognition
and because a lot of people are pretty
much everybody is some form of knowledge
worker now right there's an executive
function that you need you've got to
make a decision thing everyone's like
doing a little bit of operations it got
to be this before this and that's more
urgent and this is important but this i
can push off till tomorrow
how do you balance or how do you play
with the tension between
cognition and intuition
when you're making decisions
a key takeaway that i had from my annual
review this year which by the way i put
out publicly i'm pretty proud of it
maybe there's some good stuff in there
one of the key takeaways is that uh
i'm too smart like i'm trying too hard
to be rational
and to approach things from a very
like let's figure this out think lens
and i'm actually like this is a little
bit tug and cheek but this year i'm
trying to be less smart
i don't need to
like know what's going on it's more
about that i can trust myself to to do
the right thing and this is much more of
a
reliance on intuition and feeling i talk
about like listening to the signals our
bodies are telling us listening to our
emotions trusting our gut
and i think it's important to recognize
that for me when i say intuition i mean
internalized experience that the more
that i have done something the more that
i have internalized the right way of
doing it that so much of it is
subconscious and that if i'm trying to
think about the reasons for doing it or
my strategy for doing it or optimizing
it i'm getting in the way of my natural
brilliance
and that this intuition because it comes
from internalized experience if i have
no experience it's not going to come
overnight my i'm not going to be well
calibrated so
this is important because if i'm taking
a long-term perspective
i need to be getting more experience so
that my intuition becomes something that
i can rely upon so does this does this
look like beginning
at the beginning of the pursuit you're
more deliberate you're more cerebral and
then as you continue and you accumulate
more experience then you allow that
intuition to take over is that the way
to look at this
yes and i would take it even farther is
i want to be very tolerant of making big
mistakes in the beginning by trusting my
gut knowing that my knowing that my
intuition is not going to be well
calibrated yet but because it's going to
get me more reps and more feedback and
more evidence of where i am calibrated
right it's like i want to
i want to be optimizing for speed
and the this process of needing to be
very deliberate slows things down just
so many opportunities in life especially
in the physical world are very temporal
like you see the person across the room
like oh i should go talk to that person
you can't be thinking about the perfect
opener or the perfe or like checking
their twitter feed looking for the right
thing to ask them about just go up and
say what's up right trust your intuition
on that and so i'm trying to just say oh
i think i should do this just doing it
just just trusting it and if i'm wrong i
can go back and calibrate that later
it's like okay here are the things that
i might have missed or here's what i
might have done differently next time
right the time for that the liberation
can be there but not in the moment and
the moment you just go for it in in
poker i think about this as like
confident versus critical so i like to
give poker examples so imagine that i'm
playing in this very very high stakes
tournament and i'm in there with people
who like this is just a rounding error
for them this is no big deal so if i
look like i'm really try hard they're
going to try harder i want them to relax
i want them to and i also want them to
be a little bit intimidated by me right
the easier that i make it look
the more that they're going to say hey
like he's too good maybe i want to just
like let it have it so i at the table i
want to be embodying like i'm gonna win
this tournament guys like it's just a
matter of time like i know it i am fully
confident and so every bluff that i make
every raise every call i'm like man i'm
just like the greatest poker player in
the universe this is amazing like
everything i do everything i touch turns
to gold now obviously i can't believe
that and i don't believe that the second
that the tournament ends i move into
fully critical mode and be like wow like
i just played like garbage it doesn't
matter that i want a million dollars
like i made a bunch of mistakes so i'm
going to go back to all of those places
that i could have done things
differently and deconstruct it and
figure it out so that when i come back
to that next situation not only do i
have the evidence and the confidence
like yeah i've studied this spot i'm
prepared like i know exactly what i'm
doing i'm just going to trust it but
that i'm likely to do better in that
time or i'm likely to move faster i'm
likely to not hesitate so it's this
dichotomy that's so supportive is just
trusting intuition but then you know
when the curtains closed i have the time
to sit back and reflect i can say all
right well i messed up a bunch there
let's figure out how i messed up so i
don't make that same mistake again
didn't you work on how you were going to
put the money down on the table
like that like the the body language and
the sensor what was that
yeah i practiced
over and over again looking at my cards
grabbing chips and putting them into the
middle so that i could have not only so
i wouldn't giving anything away so that
no matter what i had that that would
feel like second nature to me but also
to just kind of reclaim some of that
mental bandwidth so while i'm doing that
rather than focusing on the movement
itself i could be thinking about what
the right play is to make is just trying
to make something second nature so that
i don't have to even think about it dude
so this thing that i came up with it's
opportunity anxiety so opportunity cost
is that by doing a thing you are not
able to do another thing right you have
the choice between the theme park in the
gym by going to the theme park you can't
go to the gym the opportunity cost of
going to the theme park is not being
able to go to the gym right
i'm adamant that there's an equivalent
around opportunity anxiety and it shows
itself in daily routines best of all so
the daily habits or practices that you
need to do
they reset every morning when you wake
up so as you wake up on the morning you
now have this
like this list i've got to meditate and
i've got to go to the gym and i've got
to walk the dog and i've got to check my
emails and i'm going to do blah blah
blah
the longer that you leave those things
without them being done
the more time is spent thinking about
the fact that you still need to do them
so this is an argument for front loading
tasks and especially personal
productivity tasks earlier in the day if
you have committed to yourself that
you're going to read 10 pages and
meditate and do some breath work
you can either do them upon waking and
then spend the rest of the day basking
in the glow of having been such a smart
ass that you already did it
or you can spend most of the day
thinking oh god i'm so good at still
going to meditate later on and i [ __ ]
still get i've got to read the 10 pages
of that book later on every single one
of those thoughts that you had that is
your anxiety cost right that's the
opportunity anxiety cost the anxiety
cost is you could have spent this time
thinking about something else by doing
the task earlier and that's the same as
there's a cute girl or guy or an
interesting person on the other side of
the room at the party
go and speak to them because the
alternative is thinking about going and
speaking to them for the next five
minutes and that is that's not achieving
anything that's the cost that you are
paying right the anxiety cost is the
cost that you pay for not doing anything
sooner rather than later
that's so brilliant and i think it's so
well said as well is
the way that you enjoy your life is just
to have no regrets i think that's one of
the
the real costs of of putting things off
is that they're still hanging above you
you're still coming back to them maybe
feeling bad that oh i should have done
that already or man like i would be
enjoying this time with my friends or
family a lot more if i knew that as soon
as they went to bed or as soon as they
left i'm gonna have to do this thing
that i've been putting off and yeah i
always come back to just wanting to do
my best and if i've done my best i have
nothing to regret and i just enjoy
things a lot more
one thing that i would add to that when
it comes to things like habits and
routines
is
to just think about trying to find the
magic in the mundane
i think it's very easy to fall into the
trap of thinking like something like
meditation
or exercise
or
writing in the morning or whatever your
daily habit is as something to get
through in order to get on with your day
and that there is infinite depth to any
of these activities that you keep on
doing and infinite magic if only you can
pay attention to it a breakthrough for
me was you know we talked about the uh
the fantasy of running off to the ashram
well i had this fantasy at one time when
i go i went and stayed at an ashram for
a week when i was traveling i was in my
you know 30 a day backpack you know
super grizzly phase and i was like i
want to see what it would be like to be
a monk so i'm going to try to be a monk
for a week and if on the surface level
these guys lives are so mundane they
wake up they sit they're sweeping the
floor they're doing dishes they're
eating the same meals every day it's
like man this this looks pretty mundane
and boring but then you realize that
their experience of the mundane is so
rich that a simple activity like
washing a dish
or sweeping the floor
could have infinite insight or just be
so rich that they didn't need anything
else that the opportunity lies within to
find the gold in these
so i've been doing the same routine more
or less for over a decade like that
first hour of the day
is like pretty much the same and i've
had periods where i'm like man like
maybe i just don't need to do this
anymore and about a couple weeks after
that i was like yep that's probably why
i've been doing that for a decade like
the day goes way better when i do those
things but it's that i forget not only i
do these things so that i can perform
better so that i could show up more for
the people that i love but i do these
activities because they're worth doing
for their own sake and every time i do
them i discover something new if i go in
with that attitude what does the first
hour of the day look like for you
i wake up i write three pages in my
journal this is the uh the morning pages
that comes from artist's way which i'm a
huge proponent of i meditate for 10
minutes
i would love to get it up more but like
10 minutes is the the most that i can
like get on a daily basis
i look at my plan for the day say hey i
decided the night before here are my top
three priorities what am i going to do
let's make sure that i have the time for
those i'll slot those into my schedule
and then i try to get some sunshine on
my face i go outside i go for a walk i
do some stretches pretty basic like yoga
type stuff but you know motion creates
emotion so that when i sit or stand at
my desk i've already kind of got some
some momentum going i already have some
ideas that have popped up and hopefully
that those can start to spill
onto the screen or onto the page so yeah
it's like capturing getting all the the
kind of mental detrios out of my head
and then like never left never looking
at it again uh meditation like getting
getting centered slowing down movement
like let's kind of like get my body in
gear and then yeah that's that's it
sometimes i'll read a chapter of a of a
book that i'm interested in um sometimes
i'll hop right in
but yeah the first hour is kind of the
same but the experience is quite
different from day to day it's not far
off from mine uh going back to what you
just said about visiting the ashram
there that is you
minimizing your anxiety cost right you
had this thing it was a potential that
was going to take up time you thought
about it a lot okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
stress test it you know i'm gonna go and
see what it's like and maybe i'll
[ __ ] hate it maybe it'll be [ __ ] uh
but by doing that you know the girl that
you obsessed over in school for months
and months and months you could have got
rid of that within two minutes by just
going up and speaking to her she might
have been an [ __ ] you might have
hated her she had bad breath or
something and then you would have been
like oh god i'm so glad i got that out
of the way or it might have gone well or
it might have done something indifferent
right but you've you've done it that's
minimizing anxiety cost the other thing
that i thought was
what people do in life when they seek
new experiences for the most part
is they're trying to create an external
stimulus
that causes them to be present
and our goal
in mindfulness and in our daily lives is
to lower the threshold of external
stimuli that causes us to be present if
you can be present when you're sweeping
the floor
then going on a roller coaster is
fantastic but you don't need any more of
it you don't need to base jump off the
side of a mountain you don't need to
have sex on mdma you don't need to you
know pick whatever it is that you do
that causes you to not be able to be
anywhere but in the present moment the
goal is to take it from being
at the peak of the roller coaster to
going on holiday to taking the dog for a
walk to just washing the dishes right
lower the threshold down to the point
where you can simply be present because
you want to be present doing whatever it
is that you want to do i think if you
view life kind of through that frame it
becomes much more of a game you realize
that what most people are doing and the
people a lot of the time that chase the
grandest experiences are the ones that
are unable to be present without them
and that makes you see the people that
constantly you know
dan bilzerian might be an example of
this i don't know how present he is or
isn't but that sort of a lifestyle would
indicate to me that somebody
if you need so much opulence and
extravagance in order to enjoy life
that that's kind of a sad situation to
be in if you can't simply be happy being
it's the naval quote if you can't be
happy with a coffee you won't be happy
with a yacht like if you can't be
present washing the dishes what makes
you think that you're going to be
present on mdma
like you know it's
that that's one of the things that came
to mind
i'm not sure i verbalized this before
but this is something that i'm
i'm confronting with myself and been
thinking a lot about is
the
the prison of expectations
and one way that this i think has been
manifesting for myself is
setting a really high bar for social
interaction
realizing that
hanging out with friends was really a
vehicle for me to
pursue peak experiences or to
kind of engage the you know
self-involved or controlling part of me
that wanted to
create these amazing experiences that
everyone thought so well of me or that
wow i can't believe i pulled that off
and accomplished that or that was so
amazing now i have all these awesome
stories that'll make me sound cool on a
podcast and realizing how
this what i was telling myself is like
prioritizing relationships and spending
time with friends was really just an
excuse to satisfy these urges that as we
said like could never really be
satisfied right there's when you've when
you've uh skydived enough times all you
need to skydive without a parachute or
you need to do uh formations or you need
to get a wing suit or whatever it is
you're always going to find another way
to keep pushing that edge that always
recedes and just coming back to no is
like i
spend time with people because i value
spending time with people and being
comfortable releasing these expectations
of i need to be doing these amazing
things and i need to be hanging out with
like this caliber of people are like i'm
just not going to do it or it's like a
waste of time whatever story that i told
myself to justify just not sending a
text to my friends realizing like no
like we can just like
sit and hang out and do nothing and if
you're with people who you love and you
care about that's enough so yeah i think
that for me i'm said i'm still trying to
like you know figure this out but it
came back to these
expectations
of
these expectations not only were they
never going to be met because i would
keep raising the bar but they were
getting in the way of doing the thing
that i value
so i think these examples come up all
the time of
needing to hit this bar
but these expectations preventing the
action that allows you to move towards
it
talk to me about
dealing with emotions when you need to
be
uh
rational effective
performing well or just equanimous you
know
what did you learn during this intense
period of preparing for your poker game
where you knew that there was a chance
that you would win but also a good
chance that you would lose as well and
you're there trying to make decisions
under super super high pressure and then
the card's going to turn over and it's a
10 rather than a king
talk me through what you learned about
processing emotions and dealing with
them
emotions are a friend rather than the
enemy i think i think for a lot of my
life uh you know i
i would post on
rationalist forums and all of the books
that i would read would be on cognitive
biases and i thought that i could just
reprogram my code to be
robotic to just become this you know
robotic executor who just shows up and
does the work every day or to
you know make these perfect decisions
for large amounts of money and just not
care about what happened that you know
not let emotion creep into it
and the truth is that there is
no separation of emotion from action or
decision that the emotion is the
catalyst is the core component of these
things and so by trying to suppress or
repress
emotion we're it's like we're we're
sweeping it under the rug and it's just
gonna pop out somewhere else right like
we're sticking our finger in one hole
and it's gonna pop out of another hole
it's going to come out in some form and
the more that we try to deny what we're
feeling the more that we're going to
it's going to show up
in strange ways
my meditation teacher calls this instant
karma where like you know we we deny
that we are angry or frustrated about
something and we immediately like slam
the door on our finger or we like trip
or fall it's sort of like your verse is
kind of like giving these signs like hey
like maybe you aren't quite as
i can never pronounce this word
equinaminous in this moment as you like
to believe uh this like this is probably
a signal that maybe you should just like
you know take it down a notch and the
the saying that i always love is the key
is to not feel feelings about feeling
feelings right
you feel sad you feel angry you feel
guilty you feel frustrated like don't
feel angry
or disappointed that you feel sad just
feel sad sit with that and this will
allow you to try to deconstruct like why
am i feeling what i'm feeling right now
where is that coming from and it allows
you to have a little bit more of a
friendly
relationship with that emotion rather
than an antagonistic relationship
because these emotions these are signals
from your subconscious these are things
that you are experiencing they have
valuable things to tell you so when i'm
in a big poker hand or when i'm making a
big investment decision or when i'm
talking with a client i'm trying to
pay attention to what i feel and trust
that this is valuable information that i
should listen to
dude i love it the
increasingly i think that the the
stoicism movement
that we've seen over the last five years
or so um
people wanted a secular version of like
yoga for the mind that was what they
wanted they wanted to find something
that was going to make them a bit more
agile and make them not
at the mercy of the tidal wave the
vicissitudes of life right that they
wouldn't get ragged around by it so much
but i think that you end up losing a lot
of the beauty like what would life be if
it wasn't for the fact that you actually
did care about things and got sad about
stuff
there is beauty in that there's beauty
in the fact that you get to feel the
richness of emotions
because there's a lot of criticism at
the moment around being life being far
too comfortable you know we have heating
when it's cold and air conditioning when
it's hot and we can amazon prime a tv
with netflix on to postmates ourselves
some food to our door while we sit on
the couch and blah like
one of the concerns that i have
especially around the rationalist
community is that um trying to rely on
wrangling your emotions using a list of
cognitive biases and some
cbt ends up being a mental emotional
equivalent of that very very comfortable
life i don't ever want to feel basically
any emotion that i don't want so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to use raw
cognitive horsepower to just try and
like clamp it down you know how you see
those packages on the back of trucks and
they've got those ratchets it's like
right i'm going to ratchet this down so
tight that it can't ever move and it's
just never ever going to be able to get
away and you go well
okay
but what if you just sat with the
emotion or what if you use the emotion
as a signal you know you're nervous
before you go into a poker game well
good maybe the nerves can focus your
attention maybe you're not nervous
you're excited maybe the framing of the
emotion is all of the problem and the
emotion itself is barely any problem at
all
so good um i'll start with the practical
and then i'll lead into the existential
the example that you gave of being
nervous
accept that work with it understand is
there a good reason why i'm nervous is
there something that i can do to feel
more prepared knowing that i'm nervous
how is this going to affect my decision
making how can i work with that how can
i account for it how can i adjust for it
right if i'm if i am nervous but i
pretend like i'm not nervous it's going
to cause me to overcompensate it's going
to cause me to deny it's going to cause
me to go astray so like acceptance is
always this first step right awareness
acceptance given where i am what does it
make sense to do next
zooming out a little bit this
let's say
mission
of i want to conquer my emotions i want
to become
fully rational
uh
it doesn't work
it comes back to these expectations
right it's a recipe for suffering and i
think this applies to anything where we
are trying to
look for solutions where when i reach
this point
then i will have it all figured out then
i will have everything that i need
it's hopeless like this hope of
achieving this skill
receiving this knowledge becoming this
type of person and then all of your
magical problems go away
it's hopeless it's just a recipe for
more suffering because
if and when you reach this hypothetical
place which sorry you're not going to
get there like you're never going to
remove all your biases like there's
you're always going to have some things
that about yourself that maybe you'd
like to change but like sorry you're not
going anywhere even if you were able to
change everything it's like whack-a-mole
new things would pop up in its place
like life is just this like
never-ending set of details and
challenges and if you can accept that
then it's a lot of reduction of
suffering right doesn't mean that you
don't try to think better or to make
better decisions but you don't treat
that as a project that's going to solve
all of your problems it's like you
mentioned how we take you know things
like stoicism and turn them into a
religion where it's like well we want to
reduce our experience of negative
emotion
so that our companies can sell more
products or so that we can make more
friends like we turn all of our
spirituality into a project and it's
just imposing this material frame onto
no like the point is to try to ask these
difficult but important questions not
necessarily needing an answer or
expecting this answer is going to change
us
but like we just it's just you mentioned
meditation right
why do people start meditating it's like
well it's going to give me some sort of
competitive edge like no man like you
meditate because it's like just a good
thing to do but
the more that you turn you you like
thrust all these expectations on it the
the less likely you are to stick with it
because you're going to end up just
being disappointed well let me give you
two different types of humans right and
you can look at them both in terms of
effectiveness that could be you know in
the ruthless capitalist want to make
sales world and in terms of happiness
the first one spends a lot of time
thinking about cognitive biases and
they've spent tons of time on
lestrong.com they know everything that
scott alexander's ever written and when
a decision pops up to them they'll go
through their list of biases okay so
i've got self-serving attribution and
i've got the fundamental attribution
error and i've got availability bias and
there's a little bit of doubt multiplied
by zero in here okay
right and then stoicism and cbt will
clamp down on the emotions and then they
spit out some sort of solution compare
that with the person who
has the same decision come to them and
just intuitively allows themselves to
feel what it is that they're supposed to
do it's an aggregation this big macro
aggregation of all of their experiences
they think through things and then they
just make a decision right based on how
they feel plus the surface level amount
of thinking that they need to do person
number one i don't think is any more
effective i think it's much more
laborious i think that they're more
likely to make decisions that they
overthink which actually end up being
the wrong sort of answer and on top of
that i don't think that they're any
happier because they never actually get
to feel emotions you don't ever get to
feel the beauty of nerves or excitement
or sadness or joy or anger or happiness
or any of these things whereas the other
person has a richer and quicker life you
were saying that iterating on decisions
and getting those out quicker is one of
the most important things how quickly
and effectively can i make decisions the
person that does it intuitively with a
requisite amount of thinking without
overthinking without going through this
big process of cognitive biases before
they can do something i think that's the
person that's quicker and more effective
and has a richer life that's the one
that i want to be
my intuition is telling me that as well
the dimension that i'm thinking about it
is in terms of fragility versus
robustness i i think a challenge or
let's say a detriment to over focusing
on one aspect of yourself is that aspect
becomes a crutch
right you see this in the guy who only
does buys and tries but never has leg
days like man well he can put up a lot
of weight if he's within his wheelhouse
but you know you put him on a soccer
field or you you put him in a race or
something that that requires him getting
outside of his comfort zone and all of a
sudden he's not quite the horse that you
want to bet on right i'm gonna guess the
same would be in in poker like if you
had a guy that's just a quant monster
like an absolute percentages beast but
then hasn't spent time working on
emotions or hasn't spent time working on
tells or body language
yeah when in poker their a large class
of players is completely model driven
where the way that they study poker is
to ask the computer what it would do and
try to memorize those solutions and that
works great as long as they're in a
situation that they have studied but all
of a sudden and i'm in control of this
because i can control the feel of the
play
i take them to a situation that maybe
they haven't studied and now they have
to rely on what their intuition is
telling us telling them and every time
they query their intuition nothing comes
back because they've never had to rely
upon it right and that's what i mean
about fragility is like yes like if you
have this thing that you go super deep
on it works great as long as you're
within this very narrow band of
situations but as soon as you get
outside of that it comes very
uncomfortable and
that's what life is going to do is going
to put you in situations that are
outside of your comfort zone
chris box ladies and gentlemen uh
experiment without limits is the best
workbook that i've ever found for
productivity and you're an idiot for not
charging like 300 bucks for it because i
would have happily paid 300 bucks for it
but you can get it for free if you go to
forcingfunction.com
and you can get a paper version on
amazon for like what like five bucks or
something or like ten bucks fifteen it's
at cost
yeah printing printing costs more these
days but yeah highly recommended dude
it's [ __ ] dope it is a systematic
process for every single different thing
that you need to optimize your
productivity system i it's
i send that to absolutely everybody that
wants to get on with their productivity
and what else are you doing what can we
expect from you this year
thanks right now we're really excited
about the third cohort of team
performance training this is our
flagship program i work with 14
executives to teach them my full system
for performance so sending around vision
getting clarity on what they want out of
life prioritization how do we make sure
this north star this most important
thing comes first and then systems how
do they make sure that these important
things they experience continuous
improvement so i show them how to do it
and then we sit down and i force them to
do it and we do it together and we
immediately give each other feedback
it's amazing you want to check out learn
more
teamperformancetraining.com
currentcohort starts mid-february we're
going to offer it again in september so
check that out
i open source everything that i do
everything that i learned we got some
great articles at forcingfunction.com
some cool templates if you want to plan
your day reflect on your life uncover
your top values all that can be found
there at forcingfunction.com i'm also
getting into the twitter sphere a little
bit more so if you want to see some kind
of concise things that are coming to
mind you can follow me there at sparks
marks so thanks chris
it's been a pleasure thank you so much
chris what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you